Right!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
Are you sure you don't
want to just shave it all off?
Uh...
Shave your head.
- Get rid of it.
- No
No?
Okay, well I'm going to keep checking back.
How have things been with the children?
Ah, we adore them both.
Princess is a...
four foot seven inch
ball of energy.
Ha, ha.
Oh, my god. Do they have
the faces of angels.
I bet they have the faces of angels.
-Yeah.
-Do they totally love you?
Yeah, I bet they totally love you
don't they.
Still haven't bonded properly with them.
Who wants to put up a tent?
I'm not fun enough.
Where's Princess gone? Princess?
You never do anything by the book
and it always works out.
I do everything by the book
and it never works out.
Oh, my god. Did I buy
the wrong bloody book?
I cannot believe
that he supports
Arsenal.
I don't belong here.
Well, he's young.
Switch him to Spurs.
He's already set.
And anyway I'd rather he was an Arsenal fan
than someone who switches teams.
I mean that's like
cheating on your wife.
Sorry, mate. No offense.
You're selling our flat?
Your tenancy runs out
in three months.
It's only a few weeks until
we go before the judge.
Does that mean we're going
to lose custody of the kids?
The council wants stable families.
What, what are we gonna do?
♫
Everything is going to be okay.
I mean, how do we know that
they even want to stay with us?
Because we have
a good
love.
One that can survive life.
♫
Ahhh!
Love doesn't just happen to you.
It's hard work.
If you want it,
You find it.
Whooo!
Oh, yeah!
You're not being me, are you?
To do that you need to fully
understand my, um,
philosophy of life.
You rarely hear a phrase like that,
coming from someone eating
two children's yogurts.